I believe did you make on the horizon
first and then you tried to get an
investor for dark days and night and
then you decided to make the feature how
to know that dark ism did I told you
that no you know it's just really good
at research here so yeah I wrote dark
days and nights first and that's what I
was trying to get for $300,000 and then
that's why when I did this right I was I
was dealing with people that were just
horrible and then I let them go and then
after that I was doing the short term
for under Eisen and it was kind of
inspired of dark days and that's why I
was like hey can I take dark days and
just shrink it and to maybe take because
dark days was three stories in one of 30
minutes one about the Alyssa story went
about the kaci starr e and another one
so i said if i remove the middle one and
i redo them and i connect them can it
work and it did so I rewrote everything
and it was a long process to just make
sure everything connects but I but yeah
so dark days trying to get the money
didn't work out did a short film and
then after that I rewrote the whole
script to make it fit for around sixty
eighty five thousand dollar so it was
kind of a happy accident in the sense
that you were maybe waiting for this
other money to come through it didn't
and instead of lamenting and sitting
around waiting you you just said well
I've got to shoot something because it's
all happening at the same time and those
guy didn't work and then I met the
person was like yeah maybe I know
someone who can invest but i think its
maximum 60 grand or something like that
I was like ah ok I got a possibility
here how can i make it possible because
i didn't want to rewrite another script
completely from star I had this that I
think had potential so I know I had to
do a whole rewrite and it took a good
one year to just rewrite everything yeah
and that's the thing this rewriting you
know it's getting better as the more you
rewrite and rewrite and rewrite so I did
that and I showed him showed the
business plan I fix everything send him
and he said yes so it is an accident but
while you go through it it's a freaking
nightmare right I'm wondering were you
just done with filmmaking at one point
oh no no it's always like how can I
fight them do i do something for let's
say 10 grand in Montreal
and I was just trying to find a way to
go do a feature film because I know now
I'm kind of wasting my time doing short
I need to go to the next point so I was
just trying to find ways to make
something so I was like okay maybe I was
starting to write another room movie
because under a resin is a room movie
and I was like okay maybe I can make
that film and as I was running that
other feature film that was starting
that's where i was like maybe i can make
the first one and redo it because it's
the script was done so i just had to
reconnect some layers so and it worked
out right so any any advice in that any
wisdom in like letting go of one plan
because another you know there's all
these cliches we could put in that one
but we won't but but ya don't quit don't
tell wait no no don't quit just there's
always gonna be ways and I find if this
one doesn't work for now put it on the
shelf think about I know it sucks and
the worst at this I for me it's all
about I'm focusing on one thing and I
can be on for four years on one thing
but at one point it's like be realistic
you know I mean you can of course I am
gonna wait for 1 million dollar is a lot
of money and now with all the technology
everyone is making films so if you're
going to make a one-million-dollar film
in general you it's not going to be your
first one so find ways to at least make
your first one but again make sure that
you if you're going to do something that
she's going to be having some style is
going to have your signature and then
after that yeah just don't wait on once
one idea after that you can just move on
and go do something else
you